Dance Moms has no shortage of talented
dancers but that never stopped Abby Lee
Miller from playing favorites here are
some of the most underrated dancers who
totally deserved the spotlight watch
until the end to find out who managed to
snag the number one spot Cameron bridges
Cameron made her first appearance on
Dance Moms in season four but in season
seven she was invited to join the Dance
Moms crew by Abby Lee Miller Cameron
eventually decided to leave the ALDC and
formed the irreplaceable has allowed her
to step into the spotlight instead of
being put on the back burner
many fans feel as though Cameron never
got to reach her full potential on the
show despite having awesome footwork
incredible flexibility an extreme grace
Cameron was often used as a filler
Cameron doesn't do what she wants her to
do she's gonna tell us to go home the
gorgeous dancer was hardly ever given
any exciting opportunities and oddly
enough some fans seemed to dislike her
altogether but that probably would have
changed if she'd been given the time of
day
Jojo Siva Jojo with the bow bow made her
first appearance on the second season of
Abby's ultimate dance competition
despite being ridiculously famous today
Jojo wasn't always admired by the other
contestants and let's just say that her
loud personality had a lot to do with it
Jojo joined Dance Moms in season 5 after
having made a few guest appearances in
season 4 many fans feel as though JoJo's
dancing abilities were super underrated
and they're not exactly wrong Jojo was
far from being the team's weakest link
she was a solid addition to the team and
always held her own her solos were on
point and she brought something
different to the table but some would
argue that her over-the-top personality
took away from her performances what do
you guys think was Jojo underrated or
overrated Paige Hyland Paige is often
considered as one of the weakest dancers
on Dance Moms and Abby Lee Miller never
let her forget it Paige loved to perform
dark numbers that were heavy in the
gymnastic department but hardly got
these types of dances assigned to her
she performed the least amount of solos
and was often scolded by Abby who
believed her to not have what it takes
to be a professional dancer
Nux mini fans filled that page had a lot
more to offer and would have even
surpassed Kendall if Abby had focused on
training her instead of yelling at her
on top of that Abby constantly gave
Paige terrible choreographies so she
never really got her chance to shine
Mackenzie Ziegler Mackenzie is known for
being one of the youngest dancers on
Dance Moms
she basically grew up in Abby's studio
where she was forced to live in her
sister shadow instead of focusing on her
individual talents Abby chose to compare
her to Maddy time and time again
she keeps saying I should do like it
liked you but I'm not you unlike her
sister Kenzie preferred group dances
instead of solos she had an amazing
technique and was known for her stellar
onstage dynamic mini feel as though Abby
did her a great injustice by typecasting
her and cutesy acro dances by season
four Mackenzie's confidence kicked in
and she began getting the recognition
she deserved still she's known for being
a super underrated dancer Kalani
Hilliker Kalani was arguably one of the
best dancers on the show she literally
gave Maddie and Kendall a run for their
money
unfortunately Abby continuously told
Kalani that Maddie was better than her
instead of embracing her differences and
highlighted her talents
Kalani could have done so much more but
instead she was giving acro solos over
and over again which stopped her from
showing just how talented she really was
Kalani is a natural-born dancer
Abby immediately took a liking to her
because she had incredible flexibility
and technique still she never got the
credit she deserved
Chloe Lucas yak don't even get us
started about Chloe this talented dancer
was so underrated that Dance Moms fans
everywhere are still bubbling with anger
today we can't express how many times
Chloe should have won first place but
managed to get bumped down to second
that means that you're all winner would
have been Maddie she played the role of
the underdog time and time again which
totally wasn't fair for the first three
seasons Chloe was severely underrated
it's important to keep in mind that
unlike the other girls Chloe had been
training consistently for years but
despite her lack of experience she
managed to rival with Maddie and that's
saying something
Brooke Hyland Brooke was the oldest
permanent dancer on the team and for a
long time she was considered
to be Abby's favorite but everything
changed towards the end of the series
when Brookes motivation began taking a
hit according to fans Burke was super
underrated due to her age she was 13
years old and still Dancing with nine
and ten-year-olds which did nothing for
her but when she danced with people her
age her talents didn't go unnoticed
professional dancers she wasn't being
challenged enough and lost her
motivation which led to a be thinking
she had lost her talents but that
couldn't have been further from the
truth
Brendon rum follow Brynn was often
regarded for her excellent - dancing
abilities but for some reason the
producers of Dance Moms chose to paint
her in a timid light they made it look
like she was a shy girl who was too
afraid to show emotions on stage which
did nothing for her on-screen
personality Byrne is often pegged as one
of the most underrated dancers on the
show but in reality she and Kalani were
totally on the same level
Nia Frazier it's no secret that Nia is a
wonderful dancer ok well maybe it is
Nia was hardly ever given the time of
day and some might even argue that her
flaws were broadcasted while her talents
were shunned
although Nia was far from being the best
dancer on the show she was a total asset
she knew how to build up her characters
and was the queen of group dances sure
she may have lacked some technique Nia
watch looked at your legs in the mirror
make sure they looked beautiful
but she excelled in other departments
Ileana Walmsley Ileana is a natural-born
dancer she literally has it all she's
got technique in the back and grace for
days she surpassed all of the other kids
her age by miles and miles
unfortunately her special talents
weren't utilized and Abby continuously
gave her awful choreographies her dance
numbers did her no justice whatsoever
you're supposed to be amazing and
wonderful and I'm not saying amazing
wonderful after seeing when Ileana has
accomplished since her time on Dance
Moms it's easy to see just how
underrated she truly was before you go
let us know who your favorite dancer is
and why and be sure to tell us if they
were underrated overrated or somewhere
in between and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Dance Moms and don't forget to
subscribe to the things if you haven't
already thanks for watching we'll catch
you next time
[Music]